hubcaps turned into works of art their
traditional function may be to protect
the wheels of a car but for Ptolemy el
rincón the small disks are perfect for
creating sculptures especially of
animals people think the hubcap is just
a hubcap but actually they're made out
of lots of different types of plastic so
they're very versatile with all the
different shapes and things to play with
basically that's what I'm doing on
playing what I'm working the artist
makes adjustments to the hubcaps in his
studio having studied art and design in
the 1980s he now works for himself as a
sculptor he generally avoids using
photographs sketches or templates as a
basis for his work instead he lets
himself be guided by the form of the
hubcaps themselves
sometimes I am surprised because it's
there are some elements within the
materials that I use that kind of take
over and and give it a certain character
and other times I'm surprised at quite
how difficult it can be sometimes I can
spend all day just working on one little
thing and never quite getting it right
and working it again and again and again
and and I don't know why I know when
it's right but I just do and then I'm
happy
Ptolemy's Ellington has been creating
art out of hubcaps for 15 years now some
creations can be completed in a day
others he spends weeks on the thing
about creating whether you're painting
or drawing or making sculpture the most
important thing is to be able to look
properly but it's about making your eye
and your brain work together properly
and so that you can translate the shapes
that you see in your mind into something
more physical in front of it
he's created hundreds of sculptures a
single piece fetches an average of 1,000
euros the price depends on the amount of
time invested in the work some can cost
up to 40,000 euros I kind of stumbled on
that as an idea because I used to live
near a bend where they used to collect
on the side of the road and after a
while I started picking them up because
it just seems such a waste the council
were coming along and collecting and
when they were going into landfill and
some of them were really beautiful
designs
he still scours the streets for material
to include in his artworks and continues
to collect the hubcaps he finds on the
way to his studio in Brighton his
collection is in the hundreds he orders
them according to brand size material
and shape he also gets some as gifts
from his friends and family
that's C at one that's got some a little
bit of bender which is good but the
thing that first would like I'd notice
with this would be this oval shape here
and this shape here because already to
me that's looking like a shark's mouth
so if you spin it around you've got this
kind of shape going on he also
incorporates old shopping trolleys and
spare car parts into his pieces
recycling is an integral part of his
work
I'll always try to include some kind of
recycling aspect just to try to get that
message as part of what I do out there I
think the way that the world is at the
moment I'm never going to run out of raw
materials and I certainly don't think
I'm going to run out of the drive to
make things out of them so in the future
I'm just going to keep on doing what I
like doing he's currently working on a
dinosaur made from old bicycle frames
Ptolemy el rincón is a master of
breathing new life into old materials